[Musique]
très pour en débattre nous sommes avec
un jean jacques hazan brodsky médecin
hospitalier à l'hôpital bichat à ses
côtés un vj 20 députés européens
rassemblement national bonsoir à tous
les deux messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france c'est donc
une petite curiosité du moment le test
pcr négatif qui n'est pas demander à
tout le monde on a vu dans ce sujet un
tout français qui arrive du royaume uni
doit se faire tester en revanche si vous
arrivez d'allemagne
aucune obligation est ce qu'ils font
clairement changé les rênes le docteur
et contrôler nos frontières quand je
dirais la burqa n'est pas d'avant du
fait d'avoir été vite ça la lutte a mis
cela je suis professeur de politique et
d'économie ta santé donc c'est ces
problèmes de nature plus politique
finalement que strictement médicales
sont en quelque chose que j'étudie
depuis eu plusieurs dizaines d'années
maintenant la question c'est de
contrôler avec efficacité et de sabres
et de se baser sur des faits véridiques
j'entends dire par les uns par les
autres et même par monsieur poulin qui
est passé sur votre antenne ya quelques
instants
beaucoup de faits qui ne sont pas exacts
comment pourrait-on avoir des attitudes
juste si les faits dont on parle date où
ne sont pas exacts alors s'agissant des
frontières il ya effectivement des
manques dans le système actuellement
mises en oeuvre par exemple on sait que
l'irlande largement exposée à la
variante dite anglaise et que les gens
peuvent venir d'irlande au motif qu'ils
font partie des stars se repère alors
qu'on l'a interdit à certaines îles
lointaines mais dont certains pays
asiatiques lointains dont le virus est
pratiquement absent donc ya là un
paradoxe de gestion et vouloir raisonner
par grandes catégories n'est pas sérieux
voire ne pas avoir un dispositif
effectif comme c'était le cas longtemps
à l'aéroport de roissy-charles-de-gaulle
par exemple qui souhaitent un test dont
on un résultat en quelques minutes
l'ensemble des personnes qui arrivent
quelle que soit la couleur de leur
passeport n'est pas très sérieux non
plus donc là encore on est prisonniers
et c'est dommage d'une forme de
bureaucratie alors que l'intention
général est louable ce que vient de dire
de secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes le suborner est sérieux et
vérifiable
ce qui concerne les frontaliers par
exemple trois cent cinquante mille et
quelques frontaliers qui passe d'un côté
ou l'autre des frontières de la france
tous les jours on ne peut pas
raisonnablement y mettre fin et on ne
sait pas si ces gens ont croisé dans le
courant de leur journée d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière
donc il faut beaucoup de discernement il
faut réagir de manière sérieuse à partir
de faits sérieux et non pas de céder à
des tentations politiques ou
politiciennes que ce soit d'ailleurs du
côté de ceux qui prennent la décision
que de ceux qui s'y opposent je les
renvoie à sebha blement tosatto à cet
égard hervé juvin la réponse puisque je
crois qu'on rassemblement national on
demande clairement de maîtriser
davantage les frontières avant de vous
faire agir on va écouter marine le pen
regardons les frontières je demande dès
le mois de janvier de maîtrise et de
contrôler les frontières
or tous les pays du monde on contrôler
leurs frontières sauf la france
le docteur alan gross qui nous
appelaient à plus de discernement
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
je ne vais pas lui répond parce que je
suis très largement d'accord avec lui
j'observe simplement avec un peu
d'amusement que ce mot de frontières qui
était devenu un mot à peu près tabou
dans le vocabulaire politique les
frontières c'est ce qui devait s'ouvrir
c'est ce qui devait s'abaisser
et c'est ce qu'ils devaient disparaître
entendait encore ursula von der leyen
jusqu'au mois de mars 2020
avoir un seul mot d'ordre alors que la
pandémie commence à faire rage
laissons les frontières ouvertes le
drame que l'on a vécu c'est que quand on
laisse les frontières ouvertes
l'ultime frontière c'est la peau d'où
les masques d'où la distanciation social
d'où ces séparations qui sont en train
de produire des phénomène d'isolement
dont je crains qu'il ne puisse être
dramatiques donc soyons réalistes si on
avait très vite fermer les frontières et
notamment stoppé tous les vols
internationaux venant de la chine
si l'on avait plutôt fermé les
frontières peut-être à ce que l'on
aurait mieux maîtriser la propagation de
l'épidémie
aujourd'hui et je suis d'accord avec le
professeur à ce sujet faisons preuve de
discernement
nous avons en effet des continents ou
des régions du monde où il n'ya pas ou à
peu près pas de capco vide et nous avons
ce que nous appelons des zones rouges où
la pandémie se répand continuer à se
répandre voir s'accélère et évidemment
qu'il faut des traitements différenciés
ce que je peux constater simplement trop
que parlementaires européens ayant été
appelés à réaliser quelques voyages
depuis le déclenchement de la pandémie
c'est que la france est un des seuls
pays dans lesquels on rentre comme dans
un moulin se prendre un exemple très
simple j'ai eu l'occasion de participer
à un voyage pour le contrôle du
référendum en russie avion à minsk tests
sanguins coville 19 ou pas arriver un
hôtel à moscou deux heures d'attentes
avant d'être testé d'être autorisée
arrivé dans les chambres le retour à
paris s'est passé avec une facilité
merveilleuse absolument aucun contrôle à
roissy et j'ai différents informations
qui me pousse à penser que c'est
toujours le cas là manifestement et je
partage ce que disait le professeur
faisons preuve de discernement
mais rendons nous compte qu à force de
nier la fonction des frontières
à force de nier le fait qu'il est utile
qui est un intérieur et un extérieur
on a tout simplement affaibli la france
et mis en danger les français c'est ce
que je redoute
situation actuelle d'absence de contrôle
parce que je le répète j'ai des
témoignages extrêmement récent à cet
égard on continue venant de différents
continents de pays étrangers à rentrer
dans la france comme dans un moulin
alors que nos voisins l'espagne l'italie
l'autriche et sert à contrôler l'entrée
sur leur territoire
je ne peux que le regretter c'est de
l'avis des français qu'il est en jeu
avant de vous laisser les mandats
docteur alan gross qui je vais vous
faire écouter à nicolas dupont aignan
qui pointe justement ces incohérences
parfois mal vécue par lé français alors
qu'on enferme les français chez eux on
les entasse ans dans les transports et
des magasins avant 18 heures le
gouvernement ne fait rien pour contrôler
l'arrivée des variants par les pays
européens non à l'enfermement
contre-productif contre l'ong plutôt nos
frontières que répond le médecin vous
êtes docteur alan gross qui dans
l'absolu on comprend ce que dit monsieur
jiva ou ce que dit monsieur
dupont-aignan la difficulté elle est que
la propagation du virus
elle se limite pas aux frontières des
pays
vous savez très bien qu'on a décidé que
jusqu'à d'ailleurs exemple quel
département était en rouge tel autre ne
l'était pas or vous savez très bien que
dans la réalité du vécu des français et
bien les gens circuit d'un département à
l'autre parce qu'ils avaient une commune
limitrophe
dans un département qui était rouge
foncé mais qui travaillait dans un
département qui était le gel à dire vers
où l' inverse je veux dire que la
territorialité l'adaptation locale à la
disposition des autorités locales
les maires les présidents de conseils
généraux de départementaux voir les ars
c'est cette absence de finesse qui nous
nuit et des décisions qui paraissent
être prises aller à une échelle qui
voudraient englobée dans une seule
réalité une grande diversité et je ne
parle pas de la france
outre-mer et j'entendais tout à l'heure
sur votre antenne une charmante
demoiselle gens manquent touristes dire
c'est mieux ici qu'en france elle ne le
sait peut-être pas mais la guadeloupe et
la martinique c'est à ce jour la france
donc vous voyez de temps donnée -
docteur aujourd'hui si on soit à l'est
ou à vous au mois lé voilà en martinique
on voit nous c'est plus compliqué
finalement que d'aller en allemagne un
jeune enfant bien c'est pourquoi je dis
c'est que je ne parlais pas tes des
départements français de l'outre-mer
français
mais pour s'en tenir effectivement comme
la team suivre à tout à l'heure
encore une fois là il s'agit pas de
politique politicienne sur lesquelles on
pourrait discuter longtemps mais ça
n'est pas mon propos
il s'agit de politique de santé c'est la
politique de santé
c'est ce que j'enseigne depuis tellement
longtemps que on s'en souvient plus
c'est une politique qui doit une
distingue de la politique politicienne
où les enjeux de politique politicienne
doivent c'est facile devant des réalités
qui s'appelle la propagation des virus
d'épidémiologie le fait qu'on a eu 6 156
morts en france aujourd'hui et 23 1608
nouveaux cas alors évidemment c'est un
tout petit peu moins mal que la veille
mais c'est encore terriblement
inquiétant est beaucoup trop si celle-ci
ne s'agissait tout que deux vieillards
cacochymes porter 2010 pathologie pour
après tout se dire on va tous année
normale
on avance lors d'essais que quelques
semaines c'est de moins en moins vrai et
les séquelles de l'infection par le
coronavirus sont au moins aussi
redoutable que la maladie elle-même et
affecte des gens qui ont 25 ans 35 ans
45 ans dans une indifférence d'ailleurs
quasi générale donc le vrai problème est
d'avoir une vraie politique de santé
dans la politique de santé trouve l'écho
chez les politiques tout court ce qui
s'occupe de nous représenter au niveau
français ou européens alors tant mieux
ce que je dis c'est que là il faut
partir de faits très précis de
connaissance précise et qui ne sont pas
soumises à cette espèce de dialogue un
vraisemblable c'est la seule source
d'ailleurs que j'ai trouvé très
semblables
dans ce cas 10e monsieur poulin tout à
l'heure qui manipulait des données
inexactes
mais qui avait au moins ceci est
parfaitement exact le débat entre
scientifiques n'a pas à se tenir sur la
place publique ni même sur les antennes
de rtt les visions mairie ont lancé des
regards nos serveurs ou d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs n'est pas les seuls à faire
des débats sur ce thème je vous invite à
regarder les autres bailleurs
voilà l'une des bases scientifiques pour
les débats techniques avec des arguments
qui sont d'ailleurs absolument inaudible
par l'opinion qui elle un droit de
savoir la conclusion que l'unanimité des
scientifiques peut en tirer
nous avons des autorités qui sont
embêtantes il tire des conclusions qui
globalement ne sont pas critiquable
ensuite il appartient aux politiques de
les discuter de les mettre en oeuvre
dans retenir ce qui leur semble
compatible acquisition économiques
sociales etc
d'autres arrières pensées qui ne regarde
pas les scientifiques que nous sommes
mais au moins faut-il partir de faits
véritables en tout cas vraiment ça que
vous avez certainement par des démons
ait déjà à la fin de ce débat c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on vous invitez vous avez pu
exprimer votre opinion hervé juvin la
sienne merci à vous docteur merci à
hervé juvin également d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france